früher habe ich unglaublich gerne
Monopoly gespielt mittlerweile gibt es
doch wieder ein neues Monopoly Spiel und
zwar die Monopoly Reise Edition die habe
ich mir direkt mal bestellt und
losgespielt allerdings nicht zu Hause am
Tisch sondern in real life und damit ja
Leute was geht herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen Video ich hoffe natürlich
euch geht's gut falls ihr noch nicht
verstanden habt wie das ganze aussieht
und was ich genau vor habe kein Problem
ich erkläre es euch also noch mal in
Ruhe jetzt ich muss sagen ich habe die
Idee geklaut bzw mich inspirieren lassen
von diesem Youtuber hier fand ich sehr
sehr nice und ich habe mir halt direkt
Monopoly Reise Edition auf Deutsch
bestellt ich habe keinen Plan ob das
gleiche wie die amerikanische Version
oder englische Version vermutlich schon
aber das Spiel ist auf jeden Fall sehr
variabel und ich bin mal gespannt wo es
mich hinführen wird noch mal eben zu
Erklärung Monopoly sollte ja jeder von
euch kennen falls nicht ich glaube es
ist das bekannteste Spiel der Welt das
hier ist jetzt die Reise Variante Reise
um die Welt und wie man sehen kann
gibt's hier ganz viele verschiedene
Ziele und es gibt auch sogenannte
Ereigniskarten und hier haben wir Reise
Tagebuch Karten wo jeweils auch noch mal
einzelne Aufgaben drunter versteckt sind
und egal ob irgendeinem Feld Lande oder
irgendeine Karte ziehen muss alles ist
eigentlich immer mit einem Reiseziel
verbunden und ja werde es gedacht wir
machen uns auf Reise ich weiß dann dahin
Check den Ort ab ob der geil ist und das
ganze machen wir natürlich nicht nur
einen Tag sondern mehrere Tage
hintereinander ich nehme das Spiel mit
Würfel mir dann immer einen zurecht und
Reise durch Europa vielleicht auch mal
außerhalb von Europa aber nicht zu weit
das wollte ich nämlich ganz kurz noch
klarstellen es gibt einige Karten wo man
dann wirklich nach Beispiel Niagarafälle
viel zu weit weg leider alles was über
6000 km Flug Entfernung sind werde ich
nicht machen und dann weiterwürfeln ich
hoffe ihr seid doch nicht böse darüber
und respektiert das aber Reisen ist
super anstrengend vor allem wenn man oft
den Zielort wechselt und ich möchte im
besten Fall auch die Zeit genießen damit
geile Videos für euch entstehen und ja
deswegen habe ich mir dazu aber es nicht
ausgeschlossen dass ich das vielleicht
in zwei drei Monaten dann wirklich auch
komplett weltweit mache aber wir wollen
uns jetzt eher mal ein bisschen auf
Europa fokussieren so let's go dann
wollen wir noch mal
drei eins zwei drei pytons von St Lucia
scheiße ey das ist jetzt Richtung ich
hatte Geographie LK in der Schule
deswegen weiß ich dass das ziemlich weit
weg ist aber wir gucken es nach ich
schwöre wenn es jetzt unter 6000 km sind
werde ich machen ohne Witz Leute ich
würde unfassbar gerne dahin und
vielleicht holen wir es auch irgendwann
nach aber schaut mal das sind
9100 km Luftlinie und ich habe gerade
mal nachgeschaut ich wäre unfassbar
lange unterwegs aber hier mal ein Foto
von mir wo ich dann vielleicht doch
dabei irgendwas
okay das sind 6 + 5 sind 11 jetzt muss
aber irgendwas hinhauen 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 11 die Küste von Lagos oh nein das
ist auch wieder voll weit oder
was oder ist das nächste Portugal oh
Lagos befindet sich an einem
abwechslungsreichsten Abschnitt
Urlaubsfreude klingt ja gut Portugal ob
ich es mir glaubt oder nicht ich war
noch nie in meiner ganzen Leben in
Portugal okay das sind ungefähr 2200
Kilometer und ich muss mit dem Flugzeug
fliegen nach Faro oder Lissabon um dann
noch Lagos zu reisen dann schaue ich mal
wann der nächste Flug geht und wir
machen uns dann auf den Weg nach Küste
von Lagos mal schauen wie es wird let's
go Leute einen Nachtrag noch es gibt
hier nach Flugfelder wenn ich darauf
Lande werde ich den günstigsten Flug von
der Stadt wo ich gerade bin oder dem Ort
wo ich gerade bin nehme und es gibt
Fernflüge falls ich auf diesem Feld
Lande werde ich den ersten
Langstreckenflug über 5000 km nehmen den
ich bekommen kann von dem Ort wo ich
halt gerade bin macht Sinn oder ja mehr
muss ich glaube ich nicht erklären wir
sehen uns okay Leute was geht guten
Morgen wir haben es 8 Uhr ich mache mir
jetzt auf dem Weg zum Flughafen wir
fliegen nach Faro das ist ganz im Süden
von Portugal ich muss dazu sagen ich
hatte eigentlich auch direkt nach
Südafrika fliegen können weil wir
fliegen jetzt einfach sechs Stunden 30
über München es gab keine mehr alles weg
Arsch teuer aber egal ich muss jetzt
einmal umsteigen und bin dann irgendwann
heute Nachmittag da ich glaube das ist
mein Opa
[Applaus]
so Leute angekommen am Flughafen das
Problem ist es sind Ferien das habe ich
ganz vergessen Alter es ist voll okay da
haben wir es an 49 München auf geht's
okay Leute Boarding habe ich geschafft
jetzt mache ich mich auf den Weg und
zwar wollte ich mal hier abchecken kann
mit meiner MX wurde auch in die
Lufthansa launches und die gibt's hier
und ich flieg heute auch mit Lufthansa
deswegen geht das sonst geht das
normalerweise nicht und die schaue ich
mir jetzt mal an soll auf jeden Fall
ganz gut sein es gibt auf jeden Fall
einmal die Business Lounge und diese
nato-lounge ich glaube ich komme nun die
besten Lounge könnt ihr gerne mal
kommentieren
schon so oft hier gewesen aber die
Lounge hier habe ich wirklich noch nie
gesehen das ist richtig dass man mit der
Karte hier reinkommt
Lufthansa
naja ich muss sagen dass sie reicht mir
auch schon völlig okay für mich gibt es
auf jeden Fall jetzt erstmal Frühstück
erste Eindruck hier ist so sehr
entspannte Lounge ich weiß natürlich
auch schon besseren die Luft kommt das
Senator Lounge in die ich ja wohl auch
können wir nicht Business Flieger mit
Lufthansa in Verbindung mit der American
Express dann oder wenn ich den Senator
Status erreiche ist natürlich noch ein
bisschen besser aber ich lasse mir jetzt
erstmal gut gehen weil das Ding ist ja
wenn ich gleich in München zwischen
Lande kann ich dort auch wieder hingehen
aber darum sollte eigentlich gar nicht
gehen wir wollen ja nach Lagos zu diesem
Klippen oder so soll ja wohl so
besonders sein ich bin gespannt bis
später und jetzt kam mir gerade bei mir
auch noch die Meldung rein Klima Chaoten
kleben sich an Flughafen in Hamburg und
Düsseldorf fest das wird mir auch
gezeigt haben einfach naja ich muss
sagen auf jeden Fall nicht besser als
Verkehr blockieren okay Leute angekommen
in München kleiner Zwischenstopp wir
müssen jetzt einfach 21 Minuten laufen
jetzt weiter nach Faro dann mal los hier
gibt's sogar lufthansatzt aber hier noch
irgendwas Essen ich habe nämlich noch
ein bisschen Zeit Lufthansa Senator
Business Lounge ist hier sogar in einem
mal gucken ob die besser ist okay Leute
weiter geht's also kleines Mittagessen
hier ist auf jeden Fall deutlich größer
als in Düsseldorf und gefällt mir auch
besser okay Leute jetzt habe ich wieder
meine Kamera rausgeholt gut gestärkt
geht's jetzt auf jeden Fall zum Geld und
dann geht's ab nach Portugal freue mich
wir haben schon Boarding ey der Münchner
Flughafen ist echt verdammt groß das
hatte ich gar nicht mehr so in
Erinnerung und hier in Deutschland werde
ich auch immer behindert angeguckt ich
freue mich schon wenn ich immer hallo
freut mich
okay hier ist das Geld nichts los ach
doch hoffentlich ist der Flieger leer
obwohl nee hoffentlich ist er voll muss
ja nicht sein Leute Faro war jetzt auch
für mich der nächste Flughafen er ist
trotzdem aber noch 80 km weg von Lagos
das heißt ich muss später noch entweder
Zug oder Taxi fahren ich bin mal
gespannt wie ich da hinkomme das wird
heute noch Bilder Tag
glaube ich ich sitze eigentlich irgendwo
da ganz vorne Leute aber die Reihe hier
ist komplett frei deswegen sitze ich
einfach jetzt hier
als allerletzter im Flieger gehen und
dann sieht man genau was noch weiß
[Musik]
so Leute was geht angekommen in Faro
endlich war es auch dann doch eine
relativ lange Reise wir sind auf jeden
Fall unfassbar viele Pauschaltouristen
am Flughafen wie man gerade gesehen hat
in der Stange ich bin so froh dass ich
sowas nie wieder machen werde wir gehen
jetzt entspannt mal erstmal draußen mal
gucken wie warm ist es soweit ich bin ja
jetzt aktuell geboren
ich bin einfach immer so verloren wenn
ich irgendwo ankomme so zum ersten Mal
weil ich habe ja gar keinen Plan wie es
jetzt weitergeht ich muss auf jeden Fall
92 km fahren dann bin ich im Lagos und
es gibt wohl einen Bus unten Zug ich
versuch's jetzt erstmal mit dem Bus weil
dann muss ich nicht ins Zentrum fahren
und von dort aus dem Zug nehmen also ich
hoffe ich werde jetzt ein Bus finden der
mich nach Lagos bringt vom Flughafen aus
direkt wir schauen mal
schauen wir mal englisch Lagos 16 Uhr
perfekt
ich dachte mir gerade wirklich das ist
ja so einfach kurz Zicke ziehen und ab
im Bus aber ich habe keinen Plan von wo
dieser Bus fährt es steht auch nirgendwo
hoffe mal dass ich den finde also es
kann der sein es kann der da hinten sein
es kann da ganz hinten sein Okay Leute
Bus gefunden
hat mich jetzt 15 € gekostet ich muss
auch sagen erster Eindruck hier ist echt
teuer ich habe mir gerade eine Cola
gekauft für 3,70 Digger wo sind wir hier
gelandet Portugal ist jetzt kein Monaco
ja abzuküste von Lagerhaus
[Musik]
das ist Lagos machen
okay Leute nach neun Stunden endlich
angekommen wir sind in Lagos ich muss
sagen hinter mir ist glaube ich der
Hafen sieht schon mal sehr schön aus
hier ich muss jetzt allerdings noch 3,3
km Laufen oder ich finde ein Taxi keine
Ahnung aber erstmal muss ich mich
umziehen weil mir ist unfassbar heiß
dann kriege ich mich mal besser ein die
Sonne brennt hier extrem wir haben
aktuell 34 Grad und dann hoffe ich dass
ich die Küste jetzt gleich finde 19 ich
hoffe ihr seht mich überhaupt ganz schön
weit weg oder was soll ich machen ich
muss mich jetzt hier in der
Öffentlichkeit umziehen
oh da sind aber ganz schön viele die
hingucken ey Leute ich muss auch mal
sagen an dieser Stelle ich bin so
gespannt wo ich die nächsten Tage
überall landen werde ne also das wird
ich habe auch noch gar keinen Plan wie
viele Teile ich davon überhaupt reden
möchte ob ich jetzt fünf Tage unterwegs
bin oder sogar noch mehr keine Ahnung
dieser Rucksack ist eigentlich wie ein
zauberrucksack man denkt immer es passt
nichts mehr rein aber dann passt doch
noch was und jetzt ganz wichtig
eincremen bevor ich wieder einen
Sonnenbrand bekomme
der hat sich auf jeden Fall gegönnt der
Brief und damit würde ich sagen ab zu
den Klippen bzw zu Küste
aber meine yes wir sind auf jeden Fall
gleich da der Taxifahrer hat mich jetzt
rausgeschmissen und meinte ich muss
einfach nur geradeaus zu Fuß gehen und
dann rechts schauen wir mal ob das
passiert wir haben nur ein Problem und
zwar ist das hier alles FKK Strand wohl
das heißt wenn ich da jetzt mit meiner
Dicken Kamera hier auftauche weiß ich
nicht ob die das alle so gut finden
vielleicht packe ich die mal besser weg
oder schau mal okay wow Leute hinter mir
kann man schon Klippen sehen da stehen
nur ziemlich viele Leute deswegen gehe
ich jetzt mal in die Richtung weil ich
glaube da hat mir jetzt noch besser hier
riecht aber auch schon so geil nach
Urlaub also hier muss ich wohl jetzt
einfach nur noch 300 Meter gerade
ausgehen und dann finde ich genau das
Foto vor was halt auch auf dem monopolis
drauf ist schauen wir mal es ist einfach
zu heiß viel zu heiß okay ich möchte da
ganz vorne auf die Klippe wo die beiden
stehen und dann ist eigentlich die
Challenge durch dann habe ich das erste
Ziel auf jeden Fall abgehakt das hier
ist der einzige Weg Kamera einpacken und
Bein brechen auf geht's
[Musik]
gerade sehen oh mann
ein bisschen Leitung drüber dann läuft
das schon ich bin oben Leute mehr geht
nicht ihr könnte noch weiter aber das
war ich mir jetzt mal mit meinem
Rucksack
genau das hier ist der Spot mit dem man
die Küste von Lagos verbindet
extrem windig ist heute wirklich
zuwendig glaube ich weiß gar nicht ob
ich mich verstehen können
[Musik]
rote
brauchen wir nicht da nicht drauf
gerade noch einen kleinen Abstecher in
die Gassen von Lagos gemacht ist ganz
nett riecht auf jeden Fall überall nach
Gras das ist mir auch direkt aufgefallen
und ich werde jetzt mal schauen wo ich
noch was zu essen ja bekomme und was mir
auch aufgefallen ist Leute ich weiß noch
gar nicht wo ich heute Nacht überhaupt
schlafen
auf jeden Fall schön erster Eindruck
gefällt mir hier habe ich auf jeden Fall
Fleisch bekannt Thailand gesehen
dass ich heute noch am Bahnhof Lande
fertig um ehrlich zu sein auch nicht
gedacht ich habe auf jeden Fall überlegt
wie ich jetzt die weitere Planung
gestalte und mich dazu entschieden
wieder nach Faro zurückzufahren ich habe
mir Lagos einmal angeschaut klar es wäre
cool wenn ich noch ein bisschen länger
hier bleiben könnte aber in Faro ist
direkt der Flughafen und genau jetzt
fuhr noch im Zug ich will noch nichts
sagen mal gucken ob der pünktlich kommt
aber preislich wir fahren jetzt eine
Stunde 42 7,50 €. da kann man auf jeden
Fall nichts sagen in Deutschland werden
das bestimmt 18 Euro oder halt direkt
dieses schöner Tag Ticket oder wie das
heißt na ja zurück nach Faro dann geht's
ins Hotel mal gucken was heute Abend
noch mache und dann müssen wir auch
schauen wo es weiterhin geht aber jetzt
freue ich mich erstmal auf eine
entspannte Zugfahrt in Portugal ich
hatte eigentlich auch einen neuen Zug
First Class Test machen können aber ich
glaube das Ding hat keine erste Klasse
falls ja genauso aussieht wie der hier
[Musik]
die erste Klasse
mit Essen alles drin
ab geht's mittlerweile wieder in Faro
angekommen wir haben jetzt auch schon
nach 10 Uhr bzw in Deutschland schon
nach 23 Uhr bin mittlerweile also schon
etwas mehr als 15 Stunden unterwegs und
habe mich eigentlich noch nicht für dich
ausgeht deswegen ich bin wirklich fix
und fertig ich freue mich gleich auf das
Bettchen eigentlich wollte ich aber noch
schauen was abends in Faro geht kann ich
euch noch nicht ganz versprechen ob ich
das hinbekomme aber ich habe mir jetzt
ein Hotel gebucht drei Sterne Hotel 135
€ echt teuer hier die Hotels habe ich
gedacht aber ist anscheinend auch in
Urlaubsort gratis Hochsaison und daran
liegt wahrscheinlich bis später wir sind
da sieht ja eigentlich ganz süß aus von
außen Boutique Hotel fahren natürlich
Quadratmeter sind
ja am Ende des Tages immer nur ein
komplett zusammengeschnittenes Video was
20 Minuten oder so geht aber das
romaterial ist meistens wenn ich so
einen ganzen Tag unterwegs bin oder zwei
Tage über eineinhalb Stunden und knallt
echt rein also ich kann sofort
einschlafen Leute falls ich noch in die
Innenstadt Steppe und gucke was da geht
wenn ich euch das jetzt hier ein
wenn jetzt nichts passiert ist ist dass
das Ende des ersten Videos bzw der
ersten Folge dazu ich bin sehr gespannt
wie es weitergeht das werde ich jetzt
gleich noch ermitteln ihr findet das
aber erst in part 2 denn wenigen Tagen
Ding schon online kommt abonniert sehr
gerne den Kanal für weitere Videos und
dann nach oben würde ich mich auch
freuen haut rein Leute gute Nacht ciao